[Musique]
bien lui en débat sur france 24 les
électeurs ont envoyé un signal fort en
faveur de l'europe a salué le chancelier
allemand olaf scholz en félicitant
emmanuel macron réélu à la présidence
française emmanuel macron un vrai ami de
l'ukraine a lancé volodymyr hélas qui le
président ukrainien vladimir poutine a
également félicité le président emmanuel
macron réélu un président qui fait vous
le savez de l'europe l'une de ses
priorités son premier déplacement à
l'étranger devrait avoir lieu à berlin
par ailleurs en allemagne une réunion de
40 ministres de la défense dont
l'américain lloyd austin vient de se
terminer
les etats unis sont prêts à remuer ciel
et terre pour faire gagner l'ukraine
contre la russie affirmé le chef du
pentagone alors que le secrétaire
général de l'onu a quant à lui a plaidé
pour un cessez le feu face à la guerre
en ukraine l'axé paris-berlin peut-il se
renforcer et emmanuel macron et olaf
scholz ont-ils à la manoeuvre faut-il
repenser l architecture de la sécurité
en europe on en débat ce soir avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés sabine thilay bonsoir à vous
député modem présidente de la commission
des affaires européennes à l'assemblée
nationale et puis vous êtes
franco-allemande je tiens également à le
dire bienvenue sur ce plateau en face de
vous julien terreau bonsoir enseignant à
sciences po spécialiste des conflits et
de sécurité internationale vous êtes co
auteur avec isabelle mandraud de poutine
la stratégie du désordre et c'est chez
tallandier bienvenue également par skype
nous avons hans stark bonsoir conseiller
pendant une relation franco-allemande à
l'ifri bienvenue à vous bonjour
également parce qu'avec de seattle de 10
matchs et anciens ministres britanniques
des affaires européennes bonsoir à vous
aussi bienvenue également en star je
vais commencer par vous parce que vous
avez écrit participent à une interview
chez nos confrères de l'express l'art et
alex la réélection pardon du président
français emmanuel macron en pleine
guerre en ukraine ouvre-t-elle un
nouveau chapitre de la coopération
franco allemande
oui bien entendu parler d'eux disons que
le chapitre se poursuit plus tôt
en attendant évidemment les élections
législatives et les résultats de ces
élections pour savoir si emmanuel macron
aura vraiment la marge de manoeuvre qui
ne visera nécessaires pour continuer son
oeuvre sur le plan de la politique
européenne en tout cas il sera s'il a
une majorité parlementaire derrière lui
qui l'appuient il aura un rôle
je dirais de de aïda state même presque
au sein de l'union européenne parmi les
vingt sept ça va lui qui va donner le la
hausse très largement
étant donné le fait qu'il a été réélu et
donc légitimé par cette élection est
parce qu il va évidemment déjà une très
grande expérience expérience dont ne
profitent pas en tout cas pas à ce
niveau là où notre chance il sera donc
le meneur
il sera donc pardon le mythomane le
meneur enfin il faut faire attention
parce que lorsqu'on mène tout seul
parfois dans l'union européenne d'un
locomotive s'en va et les wagons restent
sur place donc il faut faire attention
ils font les ateliers et pour les
ateliers il faut souder des coalitions
il faut se montrer convaincant il faut
savoir faire des compromis aussi mais ne
rompt oui s'il arrive à convaincre sa
villa vous êtes d'accord qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire de cette relation macron chose
comment va-t-on qualifié ce tandem pour
les années à venir je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec un stack de dire c'est une
relation qui continue qui doit
s'approfondir
ce qu'on fait d'ailleurs aussi au niveau
parlementaire puisque on a mis une place
en place une assemblée parlementaire
franco allemande pour apprendre un peu
mieux à travailler mettre nos
divergences sur la table mais il est
vrai aussi qu'on a certaines divergences
particulièrement par rapport à la
défense etc est là il ya un grand
travail entre olaf scholz et à mon avis
emmanuel macron à poursuivre ou qu'on
sait aussi que emmanuel macron et plus
le meneur dans ce tandem que olav chose
parce qu'il est plus expérimenté disons
olaf scholz il est peut-être par moments
un peu plus effacé un peu parce qu il
aime aller plus lentement là où notre
président a déjà mis des choses sur la
table en 2017 comme autonomie
stratégique
souverainété européenne des mots qui
était au début en allemagne a un peu
discuté ont comme ne prenait pas très
bien ce qu'on voulait dire par là mais
qui prennent tout leur sens aujourd'hui
à la lumière de la guerre en ukraine et
anglais merkel avait une très forte
personnalité et au mondial a marqué son
temps est-ce qu'ils vont réussir tous
les deux a marqué leur temps mais de
toute façon j'ai envie de répondre avec
un mot qui disait toujours jean-claude
juncker les relations franco allemand
suscitent souvent beaucoup de
frustration un peu aussi par rapport
dans l'aude les autres états membres
mais cette frustration se change en
douleur quand ça ne fonctionne pas donc
on est obligé d'aller dans le même sens
jean claude juncker l'ancien président
de la commission européenne julien
theron la guerre en ukraine vous êtes
spécialiste de la défense de ce plateau
la guerre en ukraine at elle changé la
donne dans la dynamique paris berlin
oui et non oui et non parce qu'en
réalité paris et berlin restent à la
traîne des autres européens et quand
vous dites effectivement un que paris
est plus avancé que berlin c'est vrai
mais on est encore quand même à paris en
retrait des autres européens qui non
seulement nous avait prévenus en faisant
la guerre arrive il faut faire quelque
chose et non leur expliquer non non on a
une posture progressive on a un système
de sanctions qui fonctionne très bien
quand ça ne fonctionnait pas du tout est
donc en réalité cette discussion là elle
est entre eux un petit peu les deux plus
réticents des pays d'europe occidentale
qui sont dits dit-on en général des
pragmatiques en opposition réalistes les
réalistes et les pays de l'est les
scandinaves les britanniques qui sont
beaucoup plus avancé est beaucoup plus
prudent au regard de moscou et pour
cause comme on a pu le voir et donc
effectivement ça ne change pas forcément
les dynamiques mais paris devra encore
pousser du côté de berlin et paris n'est
pas disons le plus rock comme on dit en
anglais le plus des commandes est le
plus grand des faucons qui qu'ils soient
vis-à-vis de la russie des dix matches n
y êtes d'accord ce que vient de dire
julien theron la guerre en ukraine est
ce qu'elle change la donne dans cette
dynamique paris berlin on a vu que le
premier ministre britannique lui était
vraiment un va-t-en-guerre de la
première heure
il a
créé un élan de la
capitale
un premier ministre il a pris des dons
de poutine aussi épris de l'argentine
regardez les presser et oui absolument
le moment de la vie s'ils ont des
l'ukraine tout a changé ici je suis aux
états unis je crois que tout a changé
ici parce que il y a trois mois six mois
puisque l'on tourne de washington
étaient la chine et le problème la chine
et les problèmes ces machines la chine
la chine et washington ont plié la
russie les classes un blanc de beyrouth
et ses bases naulleau qui est important
et avoir annoncé au prix des albums on
voyait des châteaux des arbres très très
lourd on dit ça au domicile et ça
commence à bouger un contre monsieur
poutine on va en parler justement en
star qu'est ce que l'axé paris-berlin
peut devenir un axe paris berlin kiev
pour que ça devienne un axe paris avec
kiev il faudra évidemment
clarifier la position de kiev par
rapport à son élargissement dans l'union
européenne il faudrait également
clarifier la position française et
allemande par rapport à la demande de
kiev sont entrés dans l'union européenne
tant que ça c'est pas clarifié je pense
qu'il ne peut pas y avoir deux axes par
ailleurs
comme cela vient d'être dit berlin et
paris ont toujours joué un peu de
prudence par rapport à moscou au prix de
lenteur d'hésitation et parfois même au
prix d'être critiqué par les autres
européens pour leur manque d'engagement
en même temps il est nécessaire que les
européens soient à la fois soudée
solidaire cohérente dans leur approche
vis-à-vis de l'ukraine mais il ne faut
pas demander à l'allemagne à la france
d'avoir en permanence la même position
par rapport à la russie que la pologne
ce serait excessif il est parfois utile
d'avoir différents sons de cloche dans
l' approche vis-à-vis du kremlin si en
tout cas sous réserve évidemment que
tout le monde tire dans le même sens à
savoir reconnaître que l'agresseur dans
cette affaire c'est la russie la
politique militaire qu'elle mène et d
inacceptables et j'en passe donc il ne
s'agit pas maintenant de se montrer
je dirais qu'on prie aussi pour les gars
de protein ma question n'est pas là mais
il faut une main tenir malgré tout le
dialogue
étant la mesure du possible avec le
kremlin et ça c'est un peu le rôle à de
nos deux pays je pense que ça n'a pas
changé sabine tila vous êtes d'accord
est ce qu emmanuel macron et aux lèves
choses pourraient aller voir ensemble
vous le dit mr et leurs skis à kiev je
pense que ce sera une bonne idée enfin
en tout cas c'est une demande de
monsieur zelensky monsieur m'a bien
réagi à ce qui a été dit ça marquerait
les esprits en je pense en disant que
peut-être la france l'allemagne et est
toujours beaucoup plus hésitant par
rapport aux autres est un membre de
l'union européenne moi j'étais à la
conférence de sécurité à munich début
février et là je n'avais pas eu cette
impression là c'était plutôt la trois
quarts des états membres qu'ils ne
croyaient pas à une attaque imminente de
la russie contre l'ukraine en réalité à
ce moment là il y avait un monsieur
zelensky et qui était présent il y avait
aussi les américains qui eux disaient
oui malheureusement
ça va arriver donc on était je veux dire
plus tôt je crois que l'union européenne
doit absolument changer logiciel tous
les états membres on a créé cette
l'union européenne pour faire face en u
divergences internes aujourd'hui on doit
se positionner d'un point de vue
géopolitique et avec ça on a encore un
peu de mal mais je dirais la guerre en
ukraine nos pouces dans cette direction
et si effectivement holeshot et emmanuel
macron aller ensemble voir voler dix
meilleurs élèves qui vous pensez que ça
serait une bonne chose ça créerait un
peu cet axe paris berlin kiev ça
montrerait qu'il ne sont plus en retrait
du tout alors est-ce qu'il faut créer un
axe
paris/berlin kiev je pense qu'il faut
rester très unie au niveau de l'union
européenne se positionner en semble en
tout cas par contre ça sera un signal
très fort et je pense que bienvenu pour
les ukrainiens déjà il ya déjà eu des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement décide à
cette pologne qui sont à la fiev donc
sur les médiateurs
pour rejoindre mais pourquoi je dis ça
parce que souvent l'axé paris berlin et
par moments mal perçu comme si on
voulait imposer quelque chose aux autres
états membres donc il faut faire très
attention avec cet axe là parce qu'il ya
aussi nos amis italiens et enfin il ya
lui dire il faut absolument maintenir le
plus possible et une unité un
positionnement face à l'ukraine ils vont
parler justement de cette réunion des 40
ministre de la défense qui a eu lieu à
pas loin de berlin c'était en allemagne
en tout cas cette base américaine
allemande l'allemagne à accepter c'est
effectivement une première d'envoyer des
chars anti aériens de type guépard on va
écouter tout de suite la ministre de la
défense allemande et puis on va écouter
aussi le chef du pentagone lloyd austin
qui étaient bien sûr présents
nous avons décidé de soutenir le crâne
avec des systèmes antiaériens guibard
cse de retrait n'a besoin en soit pour
sécuriser son espace aérien depuis le
sol
il faut que leur soutien à l'ukraine
arrive rapidement c'est le matériel que
nous livrons soit efficace et surtout
qu'il se fasse en coordination avec nos
partenaires alliés
afin de nous assurer que nous
continuerons à avancer sur la base de
ces progrès nous allons étendre ce forum
de la d'aujourd'hui je suis fier
d'annoncer que la réunion d'aujourd'hui
deviendra un groupe de contact mensuel
sur l'auto défense ukrainienne
et le groupe de contact sera un vecteur
permettant nation de bonne volonté
d'intensifier ensemble leurs efforts de
coordonner notre assistance et de nous
concentrer pour gagner le combat que
nous menons aujourd'hui et les luttes
qui suivront
et julien t on donc l'allemagne va
autoriser la livraison de char à
l'ukraine c'est un tournant elle rejoint
justement là la france et les autres
occidentaux
l'acceptent enfin en tout cas de
chancelier allemand accepte bon gré mal
gré avec beaucoup de pression en interne
là on a entendu la ministre lambrecht
aussi de la ministre des affaires
étrangères un qui poussait j'étais à
berlin en décembre j'ai vu un petit peu
les gens du ministère qui était déjà un
peu plus conscients de ce qui se passait
du point de vue de la russie et autres
et autres pays autocratiques et donc ils
cèdent à ça alors là on effectivement
pas de deux chars comme vous le disiez
anti aériens sont des éléments au fait
qu'ils sont pour protéger le ciel
ukrainiens qui sont nécessaires dont
l'espace de défense va assez haut donc
ça c'est intéressant président ukrainien
après c'est du vieux matériel aussi que
demandent les ukrainiens depuis
longtemps et même les industriels
allemands arai métal et une autre
société pousse pour livrer d'autres
matériels notamment alors c'est d'autres
temps qu'ils sont aussi également assez
vieux et des transports des véhicules
blindés de combat d'infanterie donc ce
que je veux dire c'est que là on parle
de 50 véhicules de défense antiaérienne
on peut aussi imaginer que même avec du
vieux matériel bernaille plus loin mais
ce qu aurait préféré faire berlin s'est
livré son matériel aux slovènes que les
slovènes donnent leur temps qu aux
ukrainiens histoire
changer d'avis maintenant ils sont mais
voilà clairement mais avec ce genre de
jeu là si tout le monde fait ça
l'ukraine est envahie dans deux semaines
et c'est terminé et au bon moment où les
américains sont en train de développer
de demander à l'industrie de défense
américaines de créer des nouveaux outils
pour aider les ukrainiens afin qu'ils
puissent gagner parce que c'est bien ce
dont on parle à l'idée ce n'est pas
qu'ils ralentissent la défaite de
l'ukraine c'est bien qu'ils puissent
gagner et bien à ce moment là
effectivement si tout le monde met
vraiment deux mois à se demander si on
va livrer cinquante blindés alors là
c'est plus la peine de penser qu'ils
auraient une ukraine indépendante un
jour danny smagghe chaîne est ce que
finalement plutôt qu'une logique
européenne on se retrouve dans une
logique bloc occidental
on a l'impression que les américains ont
tout de même fait pression pour que les
allemands puissent prendre cette
décision est ce que qu'est-ce que ça dit
de l'europe parce qu'on n'est plus dans
un axe paris berlin kiev mais plutôt un
axe paris berlin et kiev et washington
moi je dirais que c'est toute l'europe
qui est à fait peinière encore une fois
les états unis sur dawson ou défauts
comme je vous ai été à bord il y a 6
mois un bail presse 2009 à bobo cela
réussisse et ucd xin xin xin et c'est
que les polonais le letton 1 qui disait
quand même on poutine est
ici chez apple mais en angleterre on a
vu cottineau a envoyé ses assassins un
tué ses opposants sur le sol britannique
c'est comme si tu l'as en royans tester
les assassins des impôts
pour tous les français ce dans les
allées trop et nous avons fait
strictement rien jusqu'au moment de
l'invasion
non c'est le congo réveille maintenant
et comme a dit chen en 1940 il a fait
appel à rose-belle qui avait pratiqué
loi était stricte neutralité pour qu'il
faut que les arabes ont entrepris et
chacha layton et nous les utiles et
basso de tous david muscat utiles sur
les armes et définissons le boulot et
c'est ce que disent les skis bateau et
je crois enfin l'omt a été créée trésor
et à lui refusant les challengers dix
ans si on peut compliquer l'entrée de
mon prendre des mois moi je dirais
envoyer les chats et les ukrainiens bon
les maîtriser elle en a fait reconduire
leurs attaques et donc dix minutes donc
je crois que là les européens maintenant
sont en train de faire encore une fois
apple aux états unis louis qu'un changer
notre continent et c'est justement en
stark washington et ses alliés
maintenant on le sait depuis aujourd'hui
chef du pentagone a dit que washington
et ses alliés allaient se rencontrer
tous les mois pour aider militairement
l'ukraine comment l'europe peut-elle
finalement maintenir une indépendance
elle à un face à face avec la russie
aujourd'hui est ce que l finalement sa
dépendance à l'égard des états unis est
en train d'éclater enfin on le voit
aujourd'hui au grand jour ou pas
dépendance européenne en matière de
défense et de sécurité aujourd'hui ne se
pose pas c'est la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est si la survie et la
victoire de l'ukraine est par ailleurs
également aussi la capacité des
européens de se défendre face à une
invasion russe ella comptant pas
d'invasion russe on parle de défense
territoriale des pays européens qu'au
total de défense territoriale
on est forcément dans une logique
otanienne parce que la défense
territoriale des pays européens ne
relève pas de l'union européenne et
leurs élèves par nature de leur
engagement au sein de l'alliance
atlantique ça c'est une prérogative qui
a toujours existé et que personne en
remise en question lorsqu'on parle de
défense européenne de sécurité
européenne on pense plutôt au sud à
savoir notre sécurité sur le continent
africain où nous envoyons et peut-être
aussi proche et moyen-orient on nous
envoyait une mission d'observation où
nos soldats pour former des soldats sur
place et j'en passe mais tout ce qui
relève de la sécurité à l'est de
l'europe à alès l'europe à savoir sur
les frontières dans l'espace pratique et
dans l'espace de l'europe centrale
relève de la prérogative de l'otan est
aujourd'hui plus que jamais dogbé ne
sont dépendants d'aidé nationaux
dépendant des états et cette vidéo mais
ces défauts il faut évidemment l'assumer
aussi et je dirais que les états unis
ont aussi besoin des européens car les
états unis aujourd'hui ils sont dans une
configuration de d'affrontements
lourd avec un bloc autoritaire
dictatorial qui est formée par la russie
et par la chine et les états unis si
jamais décidé de ce je dirais de se
séparer des européens aux deux se disait
de se désinvestir du continent européen
se trouverait bien seul ne pourrait pas
faire face justement au défi de ce bloc
autoritaire et territoriales donc
lorsqu'on regarde aujourd'hui tout ce
qui s'écrit dans la presse transalpine a
outre atlantique dans tout l'est dans
toutes les dans toutes les maisons dans
toutes les expertises des personnes aux
etats-unis qui travaillent sur les
équipes questions de sécurité de défense
tout le monde mise sur aujourd'hui sur
une cohésion transatlantique donc de
poutine a fait un terrible cadeau aux
européens où il a fait une terrible
erreur il a fait un magnifique cadeau
aux européens il nous a ressoudé vous
êtes d'accord c'est bien parce que
l'idée justement c'était que les
etats-unis se désengageait de l'europe
comme d'ailleurs d'ailleurs pour ceux
qu'on focalise sur cet ennemi chinois
donc aujourd'hui il ya effectivement les
états unis et l'europe souffre
véritablement soudée mais je dirais pour
un moment ce n'est pas juste
conjoncturel toute façon cette relation
transatlantique cette relation avec
l'otan n'a jamais été mis en cause
vraiment il a simplement il ya des
engagements américains la salle de trois
bris mais là quand même essayer que oui
mais il ya quand même eu un appel aux
européens aussi de devenir un petit peu
plus un des plus indépendants
participent c'est effectivement cet
effort de défense de se rendre compte qu
aujourd'hui on vit dans un monde avec
des menace hybride protéiforme et il
faut y faire face d'autant plus que la
défense quand même quelque chose qu'il
faut penser à long terme évidemment même
si on met des investissements
aujourd'hui sur la table comme
l'allemagne et qui dit 100 milliards
d'euros ça va pas se concrétiser
du jour au lendemain
j'ai d'ailleurs la france elle l'a
toujours défendu je veux dire quand on
est arrivés en 2017 on a voté une loi de
programmation militaire de presque 300
milliards d'euros et on tient la
trajectoire mais ça c'est juste pour
mettre aussi nos armes et je vais dire
les moderniser et la mettre à la hauteur
des besoins maintenant il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin et les anomalies
posaient les allemands s'y opposer mais
les allemands feu en fait beaucoup de
poids enfin de ne pas en avant parce que
moi je m'en rappelle en 2017 avait eu
des discussions avec des verts allemands
avec des collègues des comprenait le mot
de défense simplement dans la bouche je
dirais en santé des frémissements
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il ya eu
vraiment une avancée de ce côté là il ya
de la responsabilité des responsabilités
qui sont véritablement prise c'est
curieusement seul spd les social
démocrates qui eux ont beaucoup plus de
mal parce que quelque part ça mais toute
la hausse politique la politique
qui a été menée vers l'est à un petit
peu en cause quoi aujourd'hui via
l'onglet européenne pourrait se passer
de l'otan ou pas d'un point de vue
militaire pas du tout en fait on non non
pas du tout aujourd'hui pas du tout en
fait en réalité y coopère aujourd'hui
pas mal l'union européenne et l'otan et
même des pays qui sont soit dans l'un
soit dans l'autre comme la norvège qui
n'est pas dans l'union européenne mais
qui est dans l'otan la suède et la
finlande et en ce qui concerne l'aide à
l'ukraine il ya un système de
coopération qui n'est pas le plus
efficace mais qui est un système de
coopération et qu'il ne se marche pas
dessus il n'y a pas d'opposition
frontale entre les deux blocs otaniens
et européens mais fondamentalement
l'union européenne ne peut pas se
défendre tout seul il ya eu des rapports
récents au royaume uni en allemagne et
en france sur le fait qu' en cas
d'invasion territoriale de ces pays là
aucune de ces trois armées qui sont les
plus grandes et désarmé européenne ne
peuvent défendre le territoire le
dernier à doit avoir deux trois semaines
en france est un rapport sénatorial qui
dit qu'en une semaine on a des preuves
de munitions et que en deux semaines on
commence à avoir des problèmes très
sérieux pour garder le territoire ce que
je veux dire c'est que et ça je vous
parle désormais les plus conséquentes en
europe donc en a qu'une défend une armée
européenne c'est une ambition on est
très loin du compte on est encore très
loin du compte et juste un dernier point
sur ceux sur ce set chose là on peut
être contre l'otan ou pour l'otan ce
n'est pas la question mais très
clairement c'est l'otan qui assure
aujourd'hui la sécurité du territoire
européen et aucune armée européenne
n'est capable de le faire à sa place
c'est très clair et compass de l'otan là
on parle bien des états unis est
l'alternative à ça c'est qu'il faut
mettre quelque chose comme 8% du pib
dans la défense dans tous les pays
européens plus intégrée à la fois en
termes de doctrine d'industrie
d'armement et de mg m2 pas ce qu'on
appelle la politique c'est à dire la
culture stratégique et alors ça c'est
vraiment un travail de très longue
haleine des semaines gêne ce retour de
l'otan qu'est ce qu'on en dit justement
outre manche est ce qu'on rigole un
petit peu de cette europe en se disant
elle voulait un projet de défense mais
aujourd'hui sans les américains ne peut
pas aller peut pas faire grand-chose
à 10 ans étudiant la chanson un terrain
à droite laisse mais je crois qu'elle
est pressée dixons aussi impressionné
par la faute de deux chocs de bacrot et
presto les autres leaders européens sauf
le pauvre habib et baril de près des
vecteurs un d'enlever ou steam c'est le
directorat le parrain pour la pêche et
la cnce récent de voir la différence
entre le bar se met au goût de presse
mais la question clé pour moi c est ce
que ça va pousser chante et bako a
oublié le reste a finalement décidé
d'avoir prodigué européen chaque mais
produisant ses propres fins
et des
avions de combat ça
parce que chad avions américains par
l'allemagne tout récemment alors qu'ils
auraient pu ajouter des avants français
enfin
c'est pas question qu'il faut acheter un
billion concept les folles tvnp système
tribal hostile m plus haut chaque pays a
son part de la production et oui et
c'est également un seul ce t il un avion
qui lui convient c'est le f 35 mais
après la uk si la france est prêtre
aussi vraiment de partager
européen implications possibles je peux
à peine tu me les habits de relancer un
secteur la défausse à frossay à les
impros l'album
phare que vous pouvez réagir peut-être
justement pour revenir oui c'était un
exemple bien sûr mais on en a beaucoup
parlé dans la presse que les allemands
acheter un un avion américain plutôt que
d'acheter un avion français et tout le
monde a dit alan à la voile à l'europe
de la défense
non ça c'est vraiment une haine erreurs
que je regrette énormément parce que les
allemands devaient acheter les f 35
pourquoi parce que c'est f-35 américains
vont transporter des bombes nucléaires
américaines
ça fait partie de la logique de la
participation allemande à la dissuasion
nucléaire au sein de l'alliance
atlantique on voit mal un avion européen
exécuter cette tâche donc ça c'est un
premier point ensuite il fallait
remplacer au plus vite les avions qui
jusqu'à maintenant en allemagne
transportent ces bombes et qui sont des
tornado des tornado ont vécu ils sont
tout aussi vieillot que les chars dont
on a parlé au début de notre émission et
donc on n'a pas besoin en allemagne un
besoin immédiat de mettre à la
disposition de l'armée en nombre
d'avions
quand enfin d'avion qui sont
technologiquement à la hauteur pour
assumer cette fonction
cela n'empêche pas du tout même au
contraire la réalisation du projet de
l'avion futur du combat le scaf qui est
prévu être opérationnel au plus tard en
2040 vous voyez on ne peut pas attendre
en n2 mais 40 pour pour remplacer les
tornado c'est pas possible et par
ailleurs il y aura d'autres missions
pour cet avion de combat dans les années
2040 j'en suis sûr et certain donc je
pense que c'est vraiment un faux départ
par ailleurs je reviens sur un autre
aspect à savoir est ce que l'europe est
capable de se défendre et elle m'aime
bien sûr virer ya le problème de nos
industries de défense qui sont en
concurrence les unes avec les autres
c'est un vrai sujet est un vrai problème
mais
ne n'oublions pas que le pnb de la
russie
équivaut celui de l'espagne donc on ne
peut pas me dire aujourd'hui que les
européens unis ne sont pas et ne
seraient pas en mesure sans les
américains de se défendre s'il se donner
les moyens ils en ont les moyens en tout
cas sur le plan conventionnel une autre
question est la nôtre dépendance des
états unis elle est totale c'est le
nucléaire car les russes envisage
d'employer à tout moment dans une
bataille l'armement nucléaire tactique
voire davantage
les européens n'ont comme armements
nucléaires que l'on m'offre nucléaire
français qui ne relève que du
commandement français et qui sait si un
jour on aura un premier ministre bis
blanche en 1 ou peut-être en cinq ans
une présidente le pen est ce que les
européens peut vraiment compter sur la
france pour se défendre d'un point de
vue nucléaire j'en doute et donc les
européens ont tout intérêt en ce qui
concerne les questions nucléaires de ne
pas se séparer des américains vous êtes
d'accord sabine qu'il est peut-être une
réaction sur l'avion européen d'hayange
evry autour d'accords doivent y en a en
europe des capacités quand on compte
tous ensemble effectivement on se perd
mais je crois que vous allez peut-être
me contredire 186 systèmes d'armement
treize modèles de chars plusieurs
modèles aussi d'avions de combat on a
même je crois que 2,5 millions de
soldats sous les drapeaux et les
américains en deux volets un million
mais sans cette fois plus plus efficaces
et nous je crois qu'on peut aligner
soixante mille hommes pour des
interventions extérieures donc là il ya
une vraie face à la puissance nucléaire
russe c'est ce que disait en star qu'on
a besoin de la puissance à travers
française marquantes nous aussi je veux
dire nous les français on doit aussi se
poser des questions je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
qui est englobée par la dissuasion
nucléaire pas notre dissuasion nucléaire
de nous engager peut-être avoir cette
réflexion julien t on sait toutes les
sécurités européenne en fait il
repensait aujourd'hui avec ce conflit en
ukraine c'est exactement ça on avait
fondé l'architecturé de sécurité comme
on dit sur des principes de libre
échange et de coopération entre états on
s'aperçoit qu'en fait non qui a des
tentatives d'agression et de comment
dire de conquête territoriale et il faut
repenser toute cette architecture y
compris jusqu'aux nucléaire
effectivement et quand moscou dit
effectivement que on risque de guerre
nucléaire il faut écouter moscou de ce
point de vue là y compris comme ça
gagnent lavrov dit aujourd'hui juste le
jour où les allemands alors que la
should craignait une troisième guerre
mondiale juste le jour et les allemands
décident de donner 50 tanks et sergueï
lavrov nordique au risque une troisième
guerre mondiale donc il ya des menaces
directes sur la musique lectures de
sécurité européenne je dirais quand même
encore de choses effectivement sur les
trois points que j'évoquais celui de la
de la défense collective en terme de
l'industrie d'armement sur la question
de la doctrine et sur la question de la
stratégie de la culture stratégique on
progresse en réalité dans ces trois
domaines mais on progresse on traîne
heureusement à 20 dont le sky c'est un
très beau projet la même on converge
même les allemands nous ont montré
qu'ils étaient capables de remettre en
cause leurs cultures stratégiques
la doctrine on a parlé de boussole
stratégique on avance mais la réalité
c'est que c'est des mouvements
infinitésimaux au regard de
déclenchement des risques avec une
invasion massive d'internet un voisin je
dirais aussi juste une chose qui est
très importante les images qu'on a vu
et matériels militaires allemands juste
pour que les téléspectateurs savent bien
c'est le dernier cri du matériel
militaire allemand de l'écran est petit
mais j'ai la dernière version du léopard
oui parce que c'est pas du tout ce que
les allemands vont envoyer aux
ukrainiens laisse qu'ils envoient aux
ukrainiens cd matériel qui date des
années 60 70 donc juste pour vous dire
c'est que c'est parce que les ukrainiens
savent justement utiliser que ce type de
matériel non pas nécessairement pas
nécessairement mais c'est cédric c'est
une vraie autre question c'est la durée
de la guerre c'est à dire que si on leur
envoie des matériels anciens et
notamment soviétique ils vont savoir
s'en servir rapidement et en revanche
effectivement il ya un moment où on en
aura plus en europe parce qu'en fait les
derniers pays qui en ont sont en train
de les livrer relais les tchèques ont
donné notamment des tessons 12 et un
moment on en aura plus et on parle de la
même chose pour les mig 29 et un moment
si la guerre est longue contre la russie
il faudra les former au matériel otanien
c'est sûr ça c'est une autre question je
pense que c'est le genre qui vient
d'envoyer dans la rue des formateurs sur
place
mais en tout cas ça veut dire ça veut
dire un mouvement de plus d'ampleur en
termes de capacité des smashes elle
voulait agir
comme chaque banque la france a sauvé
champlain delpierre qui sont dans le
garage
intégré dans la force l'armée française
temps au lieu de le rester dans la
garage envoyait à l'ukraine la grèce à
1340 chasseurs un avion de combat
important contre la turquie mais il peut
peut-être
une cinquantaine d'auteurs en eau pour
défendre la démocratie
il ya dix ans a offert une armée
britannique reste une l'ouest la pologne
comme camp d'entraînement en prenez
plein d les chars l'artillerie des
chauds rayons échanges de peuple
a refusé maintenant il faut aider à
créer vite
en europe et a
envoyé des six déjà mais c'est qui ce
mec ski de bosses en star vous êtes
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire danis
mcshane il faut aller plus loin est ce
que la france et l'allemagne doivent
effectivement quand je disais allez à
kiev ça veut dire effectivement
s'engager beaucoup plus dans la
livraison d'armes à kiev mais justement
c'est ce qu'on attend de la part de kiev
c'est à dire s'ils ont bien dire olaf
scholz venait mais venez avec une liste
d'une liste sur lesquels yano nos
demandes en matière d'armement et c'est
peut-être un peu la raison pour laquelle
aussi leur chance et les chances avait
tellement hésité ces derniers jours de
se rendre à kiev parce que il était sous
pression à savoir et devait fournir des
engagements militaires ferment et là
avec énorme chance a toujours insisté
aussi sur le fait qu'ils ne voulaient
pas faire bande à part qui vont l'être
je dirais encadré par un par un par un
mouvement
concerté des pays membres de l'otan pour
aider les ukrainiens et maintenant c'est
le cas avec cette réunion de randstad
c'était important parce que rammstein
c'est vraiment le hub de l'alliance
atlantique sur le vieux continent et
d'ailleurs en allemagne et avec cette
ces décisions qui ont été prises à ce
moment là maintenant je pense que
l'allemagne peut y aller donc non mais
dans la limite de ses possibilités il
faut pas oublier que les allemands
pendant en fait trente ans depuis
l'unification n'en fait que diminuer
leurs dépenses en matière d'armement que
la bundeswehr l'armée allemande elle est
chroniquement sous financé
et si autant de matériel vétuste qui
très souvent n'est pas opérationnel aux
enfants dont elle a deux tiers qui n'est
pas opérationnel à 60%
ça explique aussi les difficultés de
livraison
l'ukrainien et notamment ce qui vient
d'être dit si le conflit se prolonge
parce qu'il faut évidemment pendant plus
complètement dégarnir nos lignes de
défense y compris dans l'espace
politique est ce que ça veut dire que
l'europe qui l'ordre de demain c'est une
europe qui va se réarmer
c'est déjà le cas d'abord et on a quand
même là la boussole stratégique il était
grand temps que pour une première fois
que les européens se mettent autour
d'une table pour identifier les menace
ensemble et de voir qu'est ce qu'on peut
mettre en face son niveau capacitaires
et peut-être aussi au niveau de
structures futur de commandement pour
créer cet embryon en réalité de défense
européenne ça veut dire définir un
budget plus important une pourcentage du
pib plus important au sein de chaque
état aux enchères et à rouen les armes
et c'est ça que ça veut dire oui et
c'est pour ça que c'est important de le
dire au public aussi de la part des
médias et du politique de dire qu'il ya
une guerre sur le continent et on ne
sait pas où ça va s'arrêter vous avez vu
vous l'avais dit dans le dans le package
tout à l'heure on parle de la
transnistrie voilà
donc la russie qui disposent dispose en
transnistrie donc un qui en moldavie
enfin la frontière moldave devenue une
force militaire et pierre qui craint que
cette région soit utilisé par moscou
comme base arrière est ce que ça veut
dire que le conflit ukrainien pour être
débordé dans justement d'autres pays
européens en démarrant avec la
transnistrie oui absolument au sens
militaire je veux juste dire un truc par
rapport aux armements qu'on donne un
vieux tank ou un temps que moderne ça
veut pas dire qu'on n'est plus engagé
qu'ondine qu'on donne un un fusil
d'assaut ou un avion de combat on n'est
pas plus engagés soit pas dire qu'on va
vers ce qu'on est souvent à dire ah oui
mais on peut donner vous voyez un canon
mais de 120 mm mais pas un canon de 155
mm parce que sinon on va vers une
troisième guerre mondiale et c'est très
important de le dire aussi par rapport à
la transnistrie oui absolument on est
déjà dans une situation assez tendue sur
place il ya eu une explosion aujourd'hui
la moldavie de la présidente maya sandhu
est vraiment
extrêmement comment dire qui est une
bête noire du kremlin maya 112,7 une
militante et une avocate anticorruption
originalement alors vous imaginez ça
c'est le kremlin n'aime pas trop et déjà
sous une pression politique très
importante et d'ailleurs le président de
lens qui dit oui c'est une c'est une
possibilité j'étais à kiev il ya deux
mois et j'ai pu bien papier oui je pense
qu'effectivement ça peut complètement
déborde sur les risque d'engrenage
julien theron parce que là effectivement
on est un petit peu en escalade oui
alors pour le coup la transnistrie est
une partie reconnue par la communauté
internationale de la moldavie la
moldavie est un état européen post
socialiste qui n'est pas partie de
l'union européenne et qui n'est pas
partie de l'otan mais du coup justement
sa relance les débats avant qu'ils aient
un conflit cette fois ci comme le
demandait le président zelensky avant
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas accélérer un
peu les les principes d'adhésion qui
était déjà une question qu'on se posait
à la chute du mur de berlin d'ailleurs
et on a fait attendre les pays de l'est
pendant 15 ans pour les faire très fort
mais avant mais là c'est une autre
question qui se pose à la moldavie
aujourd'hui et vous savez là on est en
mode la vie d'un qui n'est ni protégé
par le temps ni protégée par l'union
européenne on va y revenir justement sur
cette question l'union européenne et de
l'adhésion mais avant juste encore un
point sur la sécurité des matches n est
ce que vous vous craignez tout de même
un engrenage de ce conflit parce qu'on
rentre tout de même dans une escalade
aujourd'hui
non au nom de l'idée que suggère un
peuple libre et démocratique de ce tempo
ça c'est pas escalade c'est le devoir de
chaque pays démocratique et le roi
message au kremlin messieurs poutine qui
vise à la télé ben oui on est ce qu'il
ya le parking est ce qu'il
ne sait pas et ils sont où je suis
d'accord avec le speaker ah bon un défi
gros faute en ligue europe et à durban
au bar conquis sa si bien commencée en
2007 mais après forme dire d'habitude et
on veut offrir
il faut battre pour ça la moldavie et
l'ukraine ainsi d'un saut de serbie
battue backdoor simplement petit coupé
de promenade de l'est qui créent
européen oui c'est difficile encore plus
comme la roumanie ou la bulgarie compas
base
il faut renforcer les liens l'union
européenne parce que c'est ça que
petites caisses nous tous il suffit
qu'ils aient vallier barika il est
qualifié de délinquant au plus grand que
la force on taille dans le nucléaire
dont les sillons au pis on est par un
élève
en stark j'ai lu que enrico letta
l'ancien président du conseil italien
lui il veut carrément une confédération
européenne à 36 donc prendre tout
l'ukraine tous les pays justement
d'europe centrale et orientale qui sont
soit qui ont déjà demandé lors leur
adhésion à l'union européenne soit
qu'ils sont voilà on voit de de rentrée
est ce que ça paraît comme on dire
possible d'avoir une europe même une
confédération à 36 alors qu'à 27 on a
déjà bien du mal si je puis dire mais ce
serait pas la même europe une
confédération et 36 ce serait un
ensemble qui serait pas aussi intégré
que l'union européenne à 27 aujourd'hui
et quand on parle de l'europe à 36 et
aussi parce que non se dit évidemment si
on inclut si on l agir ainsi rapidement
l'union européenne en ukraine alors quid
des pays des balkans occidentaux qui se
prépare depuis depuis plus de vingt ans
maintenant à leur intégration à l'union
européenne et à chaque fois on retarde
on retarde les échéances pour un tas de
raisons du retard parce que des critères
très précis qui sont en fait des
critères assez
sur le la corruption justement d'en
parler enfin sont des critères
la justice jusqu'à la confédération
permet de contourner certains contourner
le de mettre entre parenthèses plutôt
parce que le bon contourner et péjoratif
de mettre entre parenthèses ses critères
justement parce qu'être faire partie de
cette confédération veut dire qu'on ne
fait pas pleinement partie de l'europe à
20,7 pour confédération souvenez vous
mettront l'avait proposé au tout début
des années
indice peu de temps après la chute du
mur de berlin aux européens de l'est
justement pour éviter que les polonais
les tchécoslovaques à l'époque que
c'était ensemble les endroits entre trop
rapidement dans à l'époque c'était
encore la communauté parce que c'était
avant maastricht qui l'avait proposé ça
donc la confédération c'est une avance
chambre
c'est pas c'est pas du tout un
membership total est intégré et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle les
ukrainiens ne souhaite pas être membre
d'une confédération et veulent être
membre du club 100 % et donc il se fait
d'être membre d'une robe l'union
européenne à 28 dont qu'il pense pas
trop aux autres mais nous avons pas
seulement les pays balkaniques nous
devons aussi penser à la moldavie et
peut-être même à la géorgie même la
géorgie était encore tout petit peu à
part parce que nous n'aurons pas de
continuité territoriale avec la géorgie
mais elle a fait également sa demande
d'adhésion et la géologie fait partie
des états qui ont fait quand même des
des efforts en matière de
démocratisation
sabine cela vous êtes d'accord de saffré
une europe une espèce d'union européenne
confédération dont la frontière serait
la russie moi moi je trouve l'idée
intéressante quand même à creuser les 7
et des deux confédérations parce que
comme le disait einstein ça ne touche
pas au noyau des vingt-sept ça ne touche
pas complètement l'union européenne même
si l'europe serait différent parce que
nous devons aussi donner une réponse
justement celle du balcon de l'ouest et
certains nous disent moi je le vois
quand je suis avec des collègues en
réunion qui me disent mais à bon pour
adhérer à l'union européenne il faut
donc mourir d'abord en fait c'est j'en
ai dit je sais que si je dis ça une
manière un peu familier mais mais mais
c'est quand même une réalité maintenant
on est conscient de cette besoin
géopolitique là où ça pose problème
quand je vois dans ma circonscription je
suis parlementaire donc souvent sur le
terrain il est extrêmement difficile de
parler d'élargissement et il y en a même
aujourd'hui des personnes qui souhaitent
plutôt revenir valeureux travers la
petite europe donc il ya un grand besoin
de d'expliquer que le monde a changé et
qu'on peut pas laisser
d je dirais des territoires d'europe
dévié on doit aussi les protéger on doit
proposer quelque chose mais l'adhésion
est dans les moyens mais la version pure
et simple il n'y a pas de procédure
d'accélérer et ya pas deux il ya quand
même des règles à respecter ça c'est
très clair et ça ne rentrera pas l'union
européenne demain eux oui mais enfin il
ya une réflexion qui est quand même en
cours parce que je pense qu'on ne peut
pas laisser l'ukraine comme ça on est
amené les les les états de bol qu'on
parce que ce qui se passe quand même
avec poutine faut pas se leurrer il
s'attaque à l'ordre européen aussi et
s'attaquent à nous à notre manière d'y
vivre à nous sommes un ensemble de
droits depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale on a toujours essayé d'éviter à
ce que le pouvoir prenne le pas sur le
droit lorsqu'il fait poutine c'est le
pouvoir contre le droit et ça on peut
pas laisser faire ça ne risque pas de
diluer tout de même l'europe
non je crois qu'on a un moment un peu
historique et qu'il faut prendre un peu
la mesure de ce qui est en train de se
passer est en fête premièrement c'est
pas parce que ici on n'est pas en
ukraine qu'il n'ya pas d'ingérence ou d'
attaques russes il ya eu des attaques
médiatiques en amis disant interdire rts
foot ni qu il ya eu des ingérences
politiques avec des financements
étrangers de partis politiques il ya des
attaques clandestine avec des diplomates
qui sont renvoyés parce qu'en fait ce
sont des agents secrets on expliquait
tout à l'air effectivement dans la
sphère skripal qui a eu des tentatives
d'assassinats de personnalités russes on
est dans des modes de déstabilisation
qui n'étaient pas forcément des tanks
mais qui existe en europe chez nous déjà
donc la guerre elles se passent pas que
en ukraine ça c'est ce qu'on appelle la
guerre hybride elles se passent aussi
ici et on ose réagir l'autre point c'est
que les pays dont on parle la moldavie
les pays des balkans occidentaux
si l'europe ne les intègrent pas il y à
d'autres pays qui sont très intéressés
il ya la chine la russie et la turquie
est aujourd'hui les balkans occidentaux
on en parle très peu mais il ya une sur
division avec un gros apport russe côté
serbe et république serbe de bosnie
herzégovine et turque du côté bosniaque
et du côté kosovar est si long veut
revoir les guerres balkaniques avec
comme sponsor la russie et la turquie eh
bien on peut continuer à ignorer
poliment ces peuples en dix ans mais
enfin vous rentrerez d'ici quelques
dizaines d'années c'est ça les en
commission que la redéfinition cette
architecture de la sécurité européenne
merci beaucoup du mien theron merci
parce que sabine thilay merci à vous on
se targue d'avoir été avec nous merci de
nice le sujet merci et merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivi vous restez avec
nous sur france 24
[Musique]